good morning Hank its June 1st 2010
almost 20 years to the day since poop
from our evil and brilliant childhood
miniature dachshund red/green was found
inside my beloved Nintendo Entertainment
System so Hank as you no doubt recall I
went to bed one night without putting
the game flap down and I woke up the
next morning to find red greens poop in
the Nintendo it was a terrible day
Hank you remain the prime suspect in the
case of the poopy Nintendo you had
motive I hog the Nintendo which is true
and also I love the Nintendo more than I
loved you which is also true
you also had opportunity your opposing
thumbs combined with the ubiquity of red
greens poop in our home means there
would have been no trouble at all for
you to insert red greens poop in my
Nintendo however what I conferred you
about this you replied I intend oh you
then proceeded a place to blame squarely
on red-green himself red-green was a
very intelligent and bad dog as I
understand it Hank your argument is that
an 8-pound dog with a brain the size of
a baby fist backed up to my Nintendo one
night and pooped in it now I gotta have
a miniature dachshund and even if I did
God knows you can't make them poop
on-demand ergo to test your theory that
red green pooped in the Nintendo I have
to use science so Hank here's what I did
first I use Twitter for what Twitter is
designed for I went on Twitter and I
asked people if they could measure the
distance between the ground and their
miniature dachshunds anuses which
several dozen nerdfighters did the
average distance between the ground and
a miniature dachshunds anus seems to be
between 3 and 5 inches so Hank I have
here a Nintendo Entertainment System
flap open a stack of books the exact
height of red greens anus unless you
want to go up to the full 5 inches which
you can do by adding another book and
then I have this bendy ruler that will
serve to calculate the angle of attack
now like I'm sure the first thing you'll
notice is that a larger dog could not
poop inside of a Nintendo because this
open game flap would serve as a kind of
spit shield at the salad bar if you will
to any potential poop attacks however if
you assume an anal height of 3 inches
look at that the poop could go directly
into the Nintendo if that is dogs kept
their back straight when they poop which
they don't right we all know that a dog
poops at an angle and if you create that
angle it's about 50 degrees according to
the Internet
you cannot get inside the Nintendo no
matter how close or far away you put the
butt of the dog
this phenomenon is true even if you add
another book to create the maximum
possible height you still can't get
quite into the Nintendo now Hank I know
you're saying you're saying projectile
poop it is true that red green on
occasion was known to projectile poop
that is poop without bending his back
but given the angle of attack problem
only in a situation of projectile poop
and could red green have pooped inside
this Nintendo I think it is far more
likely that it was a human being I'm
calling dad by the way I have a pressing
question for you and I want you to
answer honestly and immediately did you
put red greens poop in the Nintendo yeah
that always works on the Mentalist
categorical denial not you so there you
have it hey mom denied it dad denied it
you deny it this leaves one of three
possibilities either one red pooped in
the Nintendo 2 a home invader invaded
our home inserted poop into the Nintendo
and then left or three someone in my
family is lying to me now I'm not saying
that person was you Hank I'm just saying
it wasn't mom it wasn't dad it wasn't me
and there's no one else in our family
and on that note Hank I'll see you on
Friday